this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription Mark Zuckerberg CEO of
Facebook and dear friend to a hundred
million real human people has an
announcement first just a reminder this
is a good company we do good things here
like providing a public space to share
news and information but did you know
sometimes people also like talking in
private weird but we're here to serve
you if the world wants more private
messaging Facebook will provide it doing
this is not easy by the way we're making
huge sacrifices over here and sure we're
not perfect we've still got lots of work
to do so don't blame us when we
inevitably messed this up and don't
expect any real tangible changes anytime
soon now if you're like me you saw this
headline yond chuckled rolled your eyes
and got back to watching a robot drive a
robot across the desert in silence but I
think that's a mistake the first part I
mean right now three of the biggest
companies on earth Facebook Google and
Apple are telling vastly different
conflicting stories about your privacy
so who can you really trust marketing
101 every company is telling a story
about who you are who you should be and
more specifically why 40 pounds of
dehydrated marshmallows which double as
a soft pillow filling material will help
you become that person some stories are
subtle others not and some can coexist
everyone loves a good Apple versus
Google headline but the truth is on the
whole the two have probably been more
symbiotic than competitive one sells
advertisements and the other screens
through which to see them
disproportionately bought by an
advertisers favorite demographic young
people with disposable income although
this is kind of just an accident
a few years ago Apple made it really
easy to block ads on your iPhone which
for them is a nice but not really
earth-shattering feature for Google and
the rest of the advertising industry it
will
less than ideal I guess the lesson is
don't let 75% of your revenue come from
a company with totally opposite
priorities the human was just crossing
the street but that's the end of the
world for the ants today the only
difference is that each company is much
more actively trying to step on the
other with their mutually exclusive
stories about collecting your data first
Google embraces it arguing that you
shouldn't just tolerate their using your
data you should want it one because
giving your phone more information makes
it more useful your phone is your
secretary and the more it knows about
you the more it can do for you it's easy
to say you value your privacy people
overwhelmingly do but then in practice
do you really care that Google can read
your email if it means you can tell your
phone to book a car and because it
already knows when and where it
automatically does it for you people
have certainly sold their data for a lot
less and to because all this data in
aggregate makes these services better
cheaper and more accessible to say
people in poverty critics argue these
tools aren't really free you just pay
with data instead of dollars well says
Google if data has value then donating
it is charity let Google see your photos
and translate gets better at reading
text which helps disadvantaged people
navigate the world really you're a hero
everything from Gmail to Chrome photos
Drive and translate relies on collecting
your data and thus convincing people of
one or both of these stories Apple
meanwhile rejects the whole concept Tim
Cook argues that's a fake trade-off
designed to justify a business model
where you are the product not the
customer not only does your iPhone not
need your data to be useful it says it
doesn't even want it for Apple storing
your information is only a liability now
whether you buy that logic or not you
have to stop and admire its genius
because if Google says your data is what
allows it to sell cheaper products then
Apple can argue it's higher prices are a
feature you should feel good paying more
for an iPhone because it's proof Apple
doesn't need to sell you out to
advertise
on the other hand this argument is also
harder to explain while tim is busy
waxing poetic about privacy Google just
points to the price tag everyone wants
to save money and finally Facebook
denies it the future is private it says
so while the old website emphasized the
newsfeed an open public place to talk
the Town Square is becoming more like a
living room
now with the redesign it's all about
private groups and communities notice by
private it means exclusive or separate
not necessarily your data stays between
you and your device or you and the
receiver in other words it gets to
capitalize on the buzzword like cloud AI
or blockchain before it without having
to make any significant changes google
also announced something new the idea is
that say you're typing a new acronym
instead of sending that data to Google
servers to determine whether it's a new
word to add to its dictionary or just a
typo your phone itself computes that
locally this way your phone can make use
of your data without Google the company
being able to see it it's similar to
Apple's differential privacy with just
as bad a name it's interesting because a
unrelated to all this phones are getting
so good that people don't feel the need
to upgrade so often using the a12 chip
on the iPhone 10s to send snapchats is
kind of like using a ford superduty to
halt your child's teddy bear but when
more work is being done on device rather
than in the cloud all that power is
suddenly useful and B if Google can have
its cake and eat it to give you both
privacy and a better product then Apple
just looks more expensive that's why
these companies are so enthusiastic all
the sudden about privacy no one forced
their hand so much as gave them an
opportunity the priorities of a growing
company like Facebook and 2010 when it
got caught sharing your private
information are very different from
those of an established dominant one
like Facebook today a growing company is
much more willing to move fast and break
things because that's what it takes it's
easy to do a bad thing get big by doing
it and then say look at us aren't we
cool for not doing that bad thing
anymore
see uber it may be strategically smarter
to fix a problem later than do the right
thing all along Facebook got where it is
today by eating up your data but now
it's an open question whether it really
needs it anymore even if every Facebook
message were encrypted tomorrow it would
still be able to show you relevant ads
how because they had years to train
those algorithms with the data they now
so courageously encrypt so they get PR
points for doing what they would have
done anyway try to draw back the kids
these days who've left in favor of
Instagram discord and snapchat Facebook
and Google have the same basic business
model selling tailored advertising the
difference is the latter provides way
more value so it can afford to be much
more honest about the trade so am I
saying don't trust Facebook yes not
because Mark Zuckerberg is evil
more like detached from reality now
don't get me wrong sometimes I like my
CEO is detached from reality
it's just that someone sober needs to
trip's it so things don't get out of
control usually we call that a board of
directors but when the CEO has the power
to a point and fire board members well
that kind of defeats the purpose
the problem is Facebook has three kinds
of shares Class A which are so
generously offered for purchase to you
and me come with one vote each Class B
10 votes and Class C come with no voting
rights can you guess which kind mark
gives to charity so even though on paper
Zuckerberg only owns about 28% of shares
he has about 53.3% of all the voting
power granting him majority control
because of this Facebook's Board of
Directors has about as much power as
North Korea's Parliament Zuckerberg will
be voted out right after Kim jong-un
loses an election okay so what about
Apple does it really care about your
privacy personally I hope not
much better the reason they build secure
private products is that they're
financially incentivized to good caring
trustworthy people retire get fired and
pass away but incentives I can trust
people who proclaim Apple just once your
money are missing the point
who knows what Apple's true motivations
are whatever
that means but also who cares zuckerberg
once said I think it's important that we
don't all get Stockholm Syndrome and let
the companies that work hard to charge
you more convince you that they actually
care more about you and I agree
billion-dollar companies tend to be kind
of single-minded so follow the business
model the only thing you should trust is
that a company will try to do what's in
its best financial interest so make sure
there's is at least kinda aligned with
yours whenever there's a big hack Tim
Cook will predictably do a few
interviews about privacy trying to
convince you that Apple's interests are
most aligned with yours with every
update Google will try to do the same by
giving you more features and more value
in exchange for your data and Facebook
will keep apologizing now it's just a
question of whose story you buy the
surprising thing about Facebook is that
it doesn't really need that much
information to know who you are as the
probability lesson on brilliant org
explains a little bit of data has a lot
of predictive power for example Facebook
sees you're visiting its website from
Berkeley California a city of a hundred
and twenty-two thousand people but you
also joined an expecting mothers
Facebook group and recently traveled to
Vancouver there are lots of pregnant
Californians and many people recently
visited Vancouver but together the
overlap is just small enough to guess
who exactly you are brilliant teaches
you the math science and computer
science behind technology like this in
interactive lessons and short easily
digestible daily challenges you can use
the link in the description to start
learning for free and the first 200
people to subscribe will get 20% off the
annual premium subscription so you can
view all the daily challenges in the
archives and unlock dozens of problem
solving courses thanks again to
brilliance and to you for watching this
video